The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WINRICH FREIWALD: So my talk is
going to be mostly about faces.
And in many ways
I'm going to connect
to what Jim DiCarlo
was talking about today
and what Nancy
talked about today.
I just thought
preparing for this
that I should say a few things
about primates and intelligence
and how face recognition
might be connected
both to the species
we are studying
and to the overall
question of intelligence.
And I thought the
most appropriate thing
to do this at MBL
would be to start
with this kind of creature.
So you might have seen
in the paper Nature that
came out last week--
that the genome of the
octopus was sequenced.
It was really heralded
in the public press
that it's finally proving
their intelligence.
The argument is that
there are 33,000 genes,
10,000 more than humans.
That's of course not a
very strong argument.
There are plants
with 45,000 genes.
So that really doesn't tell you
very much about intelligence.
But amongst those
genes that were found
were lots of genes that are
important for development
of the brain.
And there is very
high heterogeneity
in certain gene families that
are controlling the development
of the nervous system.
So it's one example of
how a better understanding
the intelligence of other
creatures in neural terms,
even in creatures like the
octopus which is very difficult
to study.
The point I would like to
stress about the octopus
is there's really nothing
social about the species.
Actually almost simultaneously
with this paper,
there was one report
about sexual reproduction
in one particular species of
octopus where it's not clear
if it's violence
or more affection.
But this is really
the one exception
to otherwise a life that's
pretty much non-social at all.
So in the octopus you have
the egg stage and then
this larva which are
hatching very early on.
There's no interaction with
mom or anything like this.
They go to the
surface of the ocean
and they start feeding and try
to grow as fast as they can
because only a few of
them are going to survive.
Then reproduction is a
very scary enterprise.
In many octopus,
the male has to be
careful not to be eaten by
the female in the process.
When it's successful, then
actually the male stops eating.
He's going to die even
before most of the youngsters
are going to hatch.
And all that mom is going to
do is basically to make sure
that fresh water is going
to be delivered to the eggs.
And that's it in
terms of social life.
So you can be very intelligent
like an octopus and, who knows,
Gabriel just mentioned
extraterrestrial life.
Maybe other species out there
might also not be that social.
And so there doesn't
necessarily have
to be a connection between
sociality and intelligence.
Second thing is it
can be very social,
get a warm fuzzy feeling
of being with others
and you get lots of
protection being in the group,
but following your
instincts in this way
doesn't necessarily
make you very smart.
So I don't want to argue
against the connection
between sociality
and intelligence
in the form of
social intelligence.
But we have to be careful
there's no necessary connection
between those.
However for primates
there is this idea,
this social
intelligence hypothesis
that really what made
primates so intelligent
is their sociality.
And so let's consider a little
bit what the arguments are.
It was most strongly put
forward by Nick Humphrey in '76,
but there are similar
precursors to this idea.
So who are these primates?
The primates are a
small group of mammals
with about 400 plus species.
They're very diverse.
You can have very
small primates,
just 30 grams, all the way
to 200 kilogram animals.
They evolved, studying
65, 85 million years ago,
there was this mass extinction.
And so you have this high
diversity within the mammals
starting from this point on.
So they have certain things
in common with other mammals,
but they're also very
special in many ways.
All of the primate
species are social.
They're not [INAUDIBLE]
social, but they are social.
They develop very slowly.
So it's really very
different from the octopus.
A lot of investment is made
into the offspring There are not
very many offspring.
And the lifespan of these
animals is pretty long.
The octopus life span
is three to five years.
They're very visual,
rather than other mammals,
which are very
olfactory oriented.
They have binocular vision,
many have color vision,
so vision is very
important for primates.
And they have on average larger
brains than other mammals have.
So our understanding of
the anatomy of primates
and what makes this special
is actually very rudimentary.
But there are a few points
that should be of interest.
So if you look at
the mammalian brains,
obviously they're very, very
complex mammalian brains.
They're not primate
[INAUDIBLE] ones.
And the main factor
really is body mass.
So the bigger an
animal is, this is
elementary of body weight
versus brain weight.
And you can see there's
a log-log relationship
between the two.
That's something that you find
all over the animal kingdom.
But if you compare primates
to other non-primate mammals
you can see that there
is a larger increase
with body mass of brain mass.
And if you count the number of
neurons, the number of brain
neurons, it is increasing
more steeply with body mass
than it is in other mammals.
This is obviously a
very crude measurement.
There are others.
If you look for brains
roughly the same weight,
you can again see
like in primates, you
have many more neurons
than in non-primates
just by these two examples here.
So there seems to be something
different in the organization.
There are other measures
you can look at.
So for example, the
neuron size is increasing
with brain size in rodents.
So a larger brain
in rodents is not
necessarily one that
has many more neurons,
but these neurons are
just getting bigger.
And in primates this is
really not so much the case.
So the size of the
neuron pretty much
stays constant even if you
decrease the size of the brain.
Or how much white matter do
you actually need per neuron
to connect other brain regions?
In rodents, apparently
the fiber caliber
is increasing with brain size.
So again, your brain
might grow just
because the anatomy
of the basic element
requires that it
will need more space.
But in primates
that's not the case.
If you get more
white brain matter,
that's likely because the
connectivity is more complex.
Primate brains also fold
faster with increasing size
than rodent neurons.
So these are all just
very coarse indications
that maybe there's
something special
about the primate brain compared
to other mammalian brains.
So along the anatomy, I
mentioned that primates
have forward-facing eyes.
They can do binocular vision,
they have color vision.
They have skulls
with a large cranium,
that's something that makes
them special from other mammals.
They're also special in other
ways that are important.
If you think about
embodied cognition,
you don't have to buy
into all these points,
but obviously if you have
a hand as complex as ours
which we share with
many primate species,
there are lots of
things you can do.
And that requires you to
be able to control it.
And this gives you a power to
interact with the environment
that other animals
might not have.
So the shoulder is
more mobile, there's
an opposable thumb
in many species.
And then in the face, there are
changes that you might already
have seen here.
So if you go up to the
more complex animals,
the snout region is becoming
increasingly reduced.
And I will tell you later
why this might be important.
So these are anatomical
specialization in primates.
Sociality is very
important as well.
And so there are four main
organizational principles
of sociality in primates.
The dominating one is
the second one here.
It's called the male
transfer system.
So it's a polygamous,
multi-male organization.
This is very important for
the social life of primates
because what it means is
that the social behavior has
to be complex.
So there can be cooperation,
like grooming, defense,
and hunting which all
the animals of a troop
might engage in.
But at the same time there's
competition for food,
mates dominance, hierarchies.
And it's a function
of the complexity
of the social environment.
So primate social
life was beautifully
inscribed by Dorothy
Cheney and Robert Seyfarth
in this wonderful book
Baboon Metaphysics.
And I'm just going
to quote from that.
So they studied baboon
monkeys in the wild and here's
what they have to
say about this.
"The domain of expertise
for baboons, and indeed
for all monkeys and
apes, is social life.
Most baboons live in multi-male
and multi-female groups
that typically include eight
or nine metrolineal families."
Which means that the
females stay in the group
and they found
families and they're
going to stay constant
over a long period of time.
"They have a linear
dominance hierarchy
of males the changes often and
the linear hierarchy of females
and the offsprings that can
be stable for generations.
Daily life in a baboon group
includes small scale alliances
that may involve only
three individuals
and occasional large scale
familiar battles that
involve all of the members
of three or four metrolines.
Males and females can
form short term bonds that
lead to reproduction, or longer
term friendships that lead
to cooperative child rearing."
"The result of all
this social intrigue
is a kind of Jane
Austen melodrama
in which each individual must
predict the behavior of others
and form those
relationships that
return the greatest benefits.
These are the problems that
the baboon mind must solve
and this is the environment
in which it has evolved."
Most of the problems
facing baboons
can be expressed in two
words: other baboons.
And so this is really important.
So again, if you're social
you don't necessarily
have to be very smart.
You can be very smart
and not be social.
But there's something
special apparently
about primates that links our
intelligence to our sociality.
So again, the Social
Intelligence Hypothesis,
what works in its favor is that
the primates have large brains.
And primates,
apparently group size
is correlated with brain size
across different species,
and not the home-range size.
This is an
alternative hypothesis
is that maybe you have to forage
in more complex environments.
And so a similar proxy
for the complexity
of your social life
and your physical life
predicts there's a
better correlation
of brain size with the social
life than physical life.
The complexity of
an individual's
social relationships increases
exponentially with group size.
And groups are not small.
And we're going to get back
to this point in a little bit.
The baboons and other primates
know their peer's dominance,
rank, and social relations.
Everything that I mentioned
in the previous slide
is good evidence
for behavioral work
that actually primates
know something about it.
This social knowledge
contrasts with surprising cases
of ignorance outside
of the social domain.
Even when it's something
as important as a predator.
So Cheney and Seyfard, they
also studied vervet monkeys.
And what they observed
is that vervet monkeys,
one of the main predators
to them is a python.
And the python, if
it crawls in the sand
it leaves behind a trail.
And there is absolutely no
indication that the vervet
monkeys make the connection
between these trails
and the presence of the python.
Which is really
striking, you would
imagine this is the first thing
that they would have to learn.
So there are cases
where they actually
follow the trail into the bush
and they're very surprised
to find a python there.
Another example
is, are leopards.
So in the environment,
leopards are
of course predators who also
feed on the vervet monkeys.
Leopards have a way of putting
the carcasses of animals
they hunted down into the trees
to protect them from larger
predators like lions.
So the presence of a
carcass would actually
indicate to you that likely
there is a leopard around.
And again, the
vervet monkeys they
don't make that connection.
So if there is a
carcas there, they're
not particularly
scared about it.
It doesn't mean that
they're ignorant.
So they're even following
alarm calls from other species
as to whether an
eagle is approaching,
or if cattle is approaching.
So it's not that they're
generally dumb in this way,
but there's really this very big
contrast about all the details
that they know about their
social world and the obliviance
that they can express
for non-social factors.
Then we have
specializations, we're
going to talk about this
in the brain for processing
social stimuli.
And then there's
actually evidence
that females who have better
social abilities, that they
are less stressed and they have
better reproductive success.
And so this all works to
say that if you are socially
smart in a baboon environment
or in the environment
of many primate species,
you actually have
better success of reproducing.
Therefore there's
a good argument
to be made that your social
intelligence will therefore
go to the next generation.
This is how social
intelligence might improve.
I think there's one
important point that's
oftentimes not made.
And that's if you become smarter
and smarter in interacting
with your physical environment,
your physical environment
does not change very much.
But if you are interacting
with a social environment,
and getting smarter
and smarter interacting
with the social
environment, the elements
in your social environment
you're interacting with,
they're also getting
smarter and smarter.
So you're actually
setting forth an arms race
where you're not only improving
the situation by getting
smarter, but we
have to get smart
in order to keep pace with the
others who are outsmarting you.
And so you can see
how there could
be a connection between
sociality and intelligence.
That there's really
this arms race
does not occur for
physical interactions
but for social interactions.
So that you actually have
to be able to better predict
the next move of someone
else in your group
and you have to know something
about that individual for you
to be successful.
So there are arguments against
the Social Intelligence
Hypothesis.
So, in particular,
we're ignorant
about many other species.
So there are other social
species, hyenas for example
have complex societies, but
hyenas have not been studied
as much as monkeys have.
We also don't know
about the complexity,
mostly for this reason,
where they're really
compared to whales,
whales for example,
primate societies
are more complex.
And this of course would
be a crucial conjecture
of this Social
Intelligence Hypothesis.
Then within the
primate orders, there
are actually some
other correlations
that do predict
brain size very well.
And so within the primate order,
social learning, innovation,
and tool use are strongly
correlated with brain size
and not with group size.
So you could imagine a scenario
where actually the evolution
of basic, social
intelligence is something
that's very basic to primates.
But then if you go
to different species
within the primate
order and ask like why
did they become so smart,
like orangutans or chimps who
can use tools, then
it really might
be the tool use that
would be of more
importance than the sociality.
So I have a movie here that
actually illustrates these two
different hypotheses.
So you see social
interactions here in a group
of Tonkin macaque monkeys.
You can see the
facial displays, you
can see that they are
tending to each other.
And well you might think that
they are trying to figure out
what's actually going on here.
And here's the alternative
hypothesis of this.
This is tool use.
So you can see this guy
just invented a cool tool,
a nose pick.
And so it's anyone's
guess what's
more important to
your intelligence,
you been able to read
the social significance
of other individuals
in your troop
or your ability to
invent a nice nose pick.
So the last point I wanted
to make is a question.
So are the primates' abilities
in social knowledge really
intelligent or is
it just more like
idiot savant-like abilities?
So a unique specialization
where they're good at.
The argument that Cheney and
Seyfard made is the following.
So the knowledge that
they have should actually
be true knowledge and just
not learned associations.
And the reason has to
do with the complexity
of the social environment.
If you have 80 different
individuals, which
is the typical case for
these baboon monkeys,
you have 3,160 pairs of
animals and 82,160 trails.
It's going to be
virtually impossible
for you to learn all
these different pairwise
relationships and then behave
intelligently based upon it.
Second, these relationships
can change very fast.
So it would not be very
smart to try and make
a list of all these
pairwise interactions
and then act upon that.
No single behavioral
metric seems
to be necessary or sufficient
to recognize associations
like matrilinear kin.
So human observers
are apparently not
very good to predict this if
they don't know the animals
very well personally.
Then you might think,
well, maybe it's
not physically like a
list but you don't really
learn this much and you
apply a simple rule to it.
And that also doesn't
seem to work very well
because social relationships
like friendships,
they are intransitive.
So if A and B are
friends, B and C
are friends, that doesn't
mean that A and C necessarily
have to be friends.
Others like family
relationships are complex,
they're non-associative.
So if A is the mother
of B, that actually
means that B is not
the mother of A.
So there's a more complex
interaction there as well.
And then finally, there can
be simultaneous membership
in multiple classes.
And again, for you to be
able to keep track of this,
you better have
a cognitive model
of what's going on rather than
just a list of associations
that you learned.
It's very difficult
in experimentation
to prove it's not
association, but I
think these are very good
arguments to consider
that actually these primates
have active knowledge
of their social environment.
So there's one example for
this where you can actually
make the point very nicely.
And this is the story of Ahla.
Ahla is a baboon monkey
and she was actually
living with farmers
in South West Africa.
So there was a habit at the
time to actually replace
dogs who were herding
goats with baboons.
And so you can see
Ahla sitting here.
You can see her
here adopting some
of the behavior of the goats.
So she's licking salt here,
which is something that baboons
would naturally not do.
She would continue to engage
in social behaviors that
are typical for baboons.
So she would groom the
goats, for example.
But the most amazing
thing about her,
which is a little hard to
see as you see her here,
she's carrying one of the
little yearlings here,
and brings it to its mother.
And the description of
what this animal was doing
was when the goats
were brought home
and then sometimes they were
separating the mother goats
from the offspring, she would
actually go manic and then
try to pair them up
and she would not
stop until she was finished.
And this would even
happen as multiple goats
were calling for the
yearlings and then vise versa.
And so she would have to put
order into the social world
that she was living in
and she wouldn't stop
until this order was restored.
And the farmer said
that they were not
able to tell any of the
adult goals or the yearlings
or know any of the pairs.
But this was like her world.
This was like a social
environment that she was in
and she would
structure it according
to her cognitive demands.
So the point is
that primates have
intricate social knowledge.
So they know about the
status of individuals,
like their age or their gender.
They know about the
interactions of individuals.
They recognize them very simply
like grooming and mothering.
And then based on
these observations
of the different individuals
in the social world,
they built these
cognitive structures
like friendship,
kinship, and hierarchy,
have an interesting,
complicated structure to them.
All of this is rooted in
the concept of the person.
And this is very
important and as I'm
going to be talking
about face recognition,
I have to emphasize these
are two different things.
You can recognize a
person from their face,
but if you can
recognize a face it
doesn't mean that you know who
it is, who is behind the face.
So the person concept would
include something like this.
It's a juvenile, female monkey.
It's the daughter of x
and so on and so forth.
So this is knowledge
that we have.
It's actually been shown in
rhesus monkeys, the monkeys
that we work with,
that they actually
have this person knowledge.
So why do we study faces?
So for us faces really
are the ideal intersection
between object
recognition, the study
of which Jim DiCarlo talked
about, and social cognition.
So as Jim was
alluding to yesterday,
vision is really
important in primates.
About a third of
the primate brain
is thought to be involved
in visual function.
So this is a lot.
And this is
testament to the fact
that there's a
lot of information
to be gathered from the
outside visual world,
but also that it's difficult
computationally to gather this.
And so Jim was explaining some
of the computational challenges
that object recognition
has to solve yesterday
and then we'll come back to some
of his points a little later.
So what is an object?
So Jim was saying that it's
the basic unit of cognition.
And just very quickly,
what it actually is it's
more than a collection
of features.
So the Gestalt
Rules of Perception
actually emphasize this.
So if you have proximity
of elements, you group
them together.
If these elements
share similarity,
you group them together
to larger entities.
If there's good
continuation, you
group these local elements
together into lines.
If that's common fate,
you group them again
together to larger entities.
And something similar
is true for faces.
If you have different
face parts, then
the wrong organization but
now you put them together
correctly, you can
suddenly recognize a face.
So there's a larger
scale organization to not
that goes beyond just being
a collection of features.
And maybe something similar
is going on for a higher order
condition that I'm sure other
people are going to talk about.
And it's in the
physical interactions,
we infer causality from
just the sequence of events.
Or social interactions,
like in Heider-Simmel movies
where you are telling yourself
a complex social story
unfold even when
there's just simple,
geometric shapes moving around.
So this creation of higher
order representations I think
is essential for
object recognition.
It's a constructive
process that the brain
imposes on the
piece of information
it gets from the eyes.
It's not just a
collection of features.
It's kind of the basis of
symbolic representations.
It can create
meaning, especially
if you think about the face,
if it's the face of someone you
know that's very meaningful.
And it makes
information actionable.
And these are really,
I think, the import
links between object recognition
and social cognition,
and faces are smack
in the middle of this.
So I already showed this movie.
To use again I emphasize
the social communication
that's taking place here.
You can see the
facial displays here.
So the older male who's
chasing the younger animal
is making these facial displays.
By the way, most of you will
never have seen a Tonkin
macaque and still you cannot
understand what's going
on there.
This is something
very special, again
that you don't have in all
animals, these facial displays.
And Charles Darwin was actually
again one of the first people
to notice it in 1872 is that
you use your face to express
your emotional state.
Otherwise your emotions
are private to you
but you use body language
and then facial language
to suppress your emotions.
And oftentimes you do it
even if you don't want to.
It just happens automatically.
And that's not possible
in all animals.
So if you are a fish
or a frog, there
are lots of really
cool things you can do.
You can sit on the front
porch and enjoy the day.
So lots of things that you can
have in common with primates.
But facial communication
really requires something
more that's very
mammalian specific.
In mammals you actually
have in the face
musculature that it's not
attaching from bone to bone,
but it's now
attaching to the skin.
And so if you look at these two
rats here where their whiskers,
I hope you can see it here,
in the end are labeled.
You can see they're actively
exploring each other's faces
in a somewhat sensory fashion.
That's possible because they
can move their whiskers because
of this musculature.
And that's a
specialization that's
becoming more and more
refined in primates.
So in rhesus monkeys
and chimps and humans,
we have 23 different
facial muscles.
They're becoming more
and more flexible.
I mentioned before that the
snout region is increasingly
reduced in primates.
So you have some
simpler primates
where there's still
a strong snout, which
is limiting the ability
of the face to move.
But the more complex the primate
is getting, the more flexible
these muscles become
and the more expressive
the faces become.
So the face now becomes richer
and richer with social signals
that can read out.
And in rhesus monkeys
which are shown here,
you have a fixed set
of facial expressions
that, again, for a system
that can analyze these,
it's very important information
about the emotional state
of another animal.
Primates are also very
interested in faces.
I'd very much like to show
this movie which is showing
a three-day-old macaque monkey.
And I'll tell you what the
point of this study is.
So you can see that he's
attending very closely
to the face of the experimenter.
Of course, if there were bananas
you might think he would also
be, this isn't proof that
there is this specialization
for faces that Nancy
was alluding to before,
but it's at least intuitive.
The second thing why I
like to show this movie
is exactly what
happened right now.
You're all getting
really excited
about this absolutely adorable,
little critter, right?
And I've seen this movie
now hundreds of times
and it's still like this.
It's still very
emotionally charged.
So here's the third reason.
The experiment is based
on facial movements here.
You can see it's getting
really excited about it,
it's getting very active.
And now he's reproducing
these facial movements
as best as he can.
There's a specific
facial interaction
that's happening
in human babies,
I think for three months.
It's happening in these
rhesus monkeys for two weeks.
And you can see that there
is an intricate connection
between what they're perceiving
and what they're acting on
in an automatic fashion.
But this emotional part I
think is really important.
It's just at a
certain point that you
can't control these things.
Faces really get very deep into
your emotional and social brain
automatically.
And so one of the lines
of research in my lab
is to try to figure
out the circuits
that make that possible
and then to use
this to get an inroad into
the social brain of function
beyond face perception.
So amongst the signals
the faces are sending,
you recognize Charles
Darwin, so it's identity,
they're getting their
social communication,
there's emotional responses,
and there's also face following.
So the direction that
the eyes are looking to,
we are following automatically.
We can control this later,
but this initial automatic
response.
Here's one very
nice illustration
from the British TV show.
You have people
wearing these glasses,
actually it's a large background
to people wearing these glasses
where their eyes are drawn
on these glasses that
are going to one direction.
And so you know that
these are not real eyes,
but what's happening
is your attention
is drawn constantly to
this upper right region.
And it's getting
annoying over time
because you know that
there's nothing there.
You know that they're not
really paying attention there.
But automatically your
attention is drawn there
and then you're going back
again and your attention
is going out there again.
And so this is
another thing that
comes from the
face that gets deep
into your attentional
control system.
So social perception can
start with faces, but faces
are the most important visual
sources of information.
We get gender and age,
of course identity,
and things like
perceived trustworthiness
or attractiveness from just a
very brief look at the face.
And then there are
these dynamical signals,
like mood and overt
direction of attention
that we also get from the face.
So how does this all work?
So Jim was already explaining
some of the challenges
of object recognition to you.
And so here are some
of the challenges.
So first of all, the social
scene like this one here,
lighting conditions can
sometimes be non-optimal.
And so the first thing for you
to analyze the facial signals
which are in this scene, is to
localize where the faces are.
And I'm going to tell you
a little bit about what
we understand about
the mechanisms of that.
Then once you know
where the faces are,
you want to analyze
them further,
you want to know who
these individuals are.
And I just realized that the
images that I had from this,
which are of course also
taken from The Godfather,
might not be the best.
Where is the other
picture of this individual
here in this display
of these five faces?
Upper right.
And then there's
another individual,
there's Don Corleone and
there's another person down here
with two different directions.
And then if the lights were
down a little bit more,
you could see this better.
The cool thing is that we have
a way of relating these two
pictures to each other
knowing that they
are from the same person, even
though physically on a pixel
by pixel basis these two
actually are much more
similar to each other.
And so we'd like to figure out
how the brain is doing that,
achieving object recognition,
in this case face recognition,
in a manner that's invariant
to transformations that are not
intrinsic to the object.
This is just a reminder that
face recognition actually
is very difficult. So this
is of course just made up
from Curb Your Enthusiasm,
but there's a condition
that many of you will have
heard about, prosopagnosia.
And to a prosopagnotic
person who is face blind,
the social world
might look like this.
So a prosopagnotic has
great difficulty telling
one individual from another.
This is at least the
most typical condition.
And you can imagine that
your social life would
be really difficult
and your enthusiasm
about socially
interacting would really
be curbed if all the
individuals looked at this
and looked all the same.
So there must be something
about the new mechanisms that's
very precise.
So what's the neural
basis of face recognition?
So the story really
starts with Charles Gross
many years back in the
late '60s, early '70s.
He was recording from the
inferotemporal cortex.
He was showing pictures
of monkey faces,
other social stimuli
like the monkey hand,
he would scramble
the face, and then
look at the responses of cells.
And he was the first to find
a face selective neuron.
Here's one.
So these vertical lines
have the action potentials
the cell is firing.
This is the period of
time his face was shown.
And this is the period of time
the control object, the hand,
was shown.
And you can see the cells
responding selectively
to the face and not to the head.
So this was a very nice finding.
It actually took him some
time to convince himself
that he could publish
it because he thought
people would not believe it.
It's recording a
anaesthetised animal.
But luckily, he did publish
it many, many years later.
And so this is
the first evidence
that there is a specialization
in the brain for faces.
He found many other cells
that like other things
and then faces
and I think people
thought that they
were intermingled
with other objects.
So this was the view.
That this is the side
view of the macaque brain.
This is the superior temporal
circuits, the one big circuit
in the monkey brain.
And all these symbols
here indicating
positions where people found
face selective neurons.
The thought was they
intermingled with object
recognition hardware.
It's basically the
view that there
is a big IT cortex where
everything in object
recognition can happen.
And yes, of course
you would have
some cells that
are face selective,
you would have other cells
that are non-face selective.
And the mixture and the
complex pattern of activity
really is what gives you
the identity of the object.
Then Nancy used fMRI to
discover face selective areas.
So first, these are
views from face areas.
We now know multiple face areas
that she was talking about
before.
So here are different
slices to this.
And the thought
from these images
really was that, no, that
maybe within this large expanse
of object recognition
hardware there
might be very specialized
regions that are really there
selectively to process faces.
And so you give the FFA, and so
the question you would ask is,
is this really a region that's
devoted to face processing
and face processing only?
Are these regions
really face processing?
Modules devoted
to face processing
or is it just the
tip of the iceberg
based on your
statistical analysis
that this region just looks a
little bit more face selective
than the neighboring regions?
And second, do monkeys also
have these localized face
areas like humans?
And you've got the
answer already.
Yes, they do.
And then what is
the distribution
of cells within these
regions versus outside?
So this is really the
research Doris Tsao
and I engaged on many years ago.
We used fMRI on macaque
monkeys, same technology
as in humans, slightly
different coils.
And this is the
picture that we got.
Very consistently across
different animals.
Here in the temporal
lobe, you have six,
face selective
regions that you find
that anatomically
specific regions there's
some variation from one
individual to the other.
But with the exception of
the most posterior area,
you actually find
all these areas
in all individuals
on both hemispheres.
There are also three areas in
the prefrontal cortex which
are a little harder to find.
But the one in
orbitofrontal cortex
is actually is as
reproducible as the one
in the temporal lobe.
So, yes there are.
Monkeys have localized
face areas like humans.
And as Nancy was
alluding to, we actually
have quite a bit
of evidence by now
that these systems
might be homologous.
Very, very difficult to prove
that they are homologous.
But all the evidence
we have so far
is really pointing
in this direction.
So how selective are
these face patches?
And what Doris and I did was
to lower recording electrodes
into these face areas
and record from cells
inside this fMRI
identified areas.
And I'm going to show
you a movie of one
of the first cells we recorded
from one of these regions.
So it's actually a video we
took from a control monitor.
So it shows the same
thing the monkey shows.
The quality is not great because
it's an actual video camera
we took to take this image.
In addition to what
the animal saw,
you will also see
this black square
which is indicating where the
animal looked on the screen
but the animal did not see this.
And you're going to hear clicks
if everything works fine when
the actual potential is fired.
Anyway, here's the
quantification.
So with 96 different stimuli in
this image set, 16 faces and 18
non-face stimuli, this
is the average response
which is normalized
between minus 1 and 1.
And you can see that
the biggest response
of this particular cell actually
of course to the 16 faces
and not to any of
the control objects.
You can see though that
there are some stimuli here
in the gadget
category, for example,
that are eliciting responses
that are quite respectable
relative to the faces.
But really the biggest responses
recorded were to the faces.
So then we color coded
this so you have a response
vector of the sale, where red
is now symbolizing response
enhancement and blue
is symbolizing response
suppression below baseline.
And the advantage
of using this format
is you can now stick
all the responses you
get from all the
cells that you're
recording day after day after
day from this one face area.
And you get a population
response matrix.
And the way that this
works is cell numbers
are organized from top to
bottom, page number from left
to right.
And you can see very quickly
that most of the cells
here are either selectively
enhanced or selectively
suppressed by faces.
There's a small
group here between,
something like 10% of
the cells, where it's not
so clear what they are doing.
But if you do the
population average,
you can see much bigger
responses to all the faces
rather than on face objects.
If you look more closely, what
these pictures are eliciting
in these intermediate
responses, these
are like clock
faces, apples, pears,
there are things that have
physical properties in common
with faces.
So you can kind
of fool the system
to give a partial response.
And this is one clue to what
this area might be doing.
It should be doing
a visual analysis
of the incoming stimuli
to try and figure out
if these are faces are not.
So these are cells in
the middle face patches.
I was actually going
over this pretty fast
but I'm going to use
this later quite a bit.
And so let's wind back.
We have one posterior area
here, to middle face areas,
see the middle face patches,
and then three anterior ones.
I'm mostly going to talk
about this one here, AL,
and this one here, M, in
addition to the middle face
patches.
So we think that actually
this is another automatic face
recognition feat.
We can't stop feeling
sorry for these peppers.
They've been just cut in half.
And so they seem
to be screaming,
and then you know
they are OK but still
you feel like something
really bad just happened.
And so we can't stop having
these inferences about peppers
where they look like faces.
And one reason could be that we
have this specialized circuitry
that's just getting active
with right features,
even if you know
these are not faces.
OK so when the faces were
discovered by Charles Gross,
this really fell on
very fertile grounds.
And I should just discuss
some of the implications.
So David Hubel
and Torsten Weisel
just discovered a few years
before orientation selectivity.
So it was a big jump
from early processing
where I could see how
selectivity of cells
was getting more complex.
More concentric representations
to elongated ones,
from simple cells
to complex cells,
but complex cells are as
selective as simple cells
but don't really have
a special location.
All the way up to the opposite
end of the visual system
and now you find a
face selective neuron.
Jerome Lettvin just had
coined the term grandmother
neuron which some of you
brought up yesterday.
The idea is that there should
be one neuron in your brain,
or this is the hypothetical
situation you came up with,
one neuron in your the brain
that's firing if and only
if you see your grandmother,
no matter what she's wearing,
which direction you see from.
That's the neural
correlate of you
perceiving your grandmother
is the activity of this one
neuron.
And there were other
concepts like Jerzy Konorski
gnostic unit that
made the same point.
Then Horace Barlow came
up with this idea maybe
it's not one cell,
but multiple cells.
But gave us a sparse
representation
of pontifical
cells, a few of them
at the top of a
processing hierarchy.
And that's actually
how we recognize faces.
And then of course there's the
opposite view of Donald Hebb.
He talked about cell
assembly since there's
no-- things are there like
large assembles] of cells.
Or Karl Lashley who
talked about mass action
and actually were
completely against
functional specialization.
If you look at a
plot like this, I
think one of the things
you want to emphasize
is that these cells
really don't fall
into any of these categories.
You can have cells that are
very, very face selective
but they don't have
to be very sparse.
They will appear sparse if
you poke them over and over
and over with non-face
stimuli because they're not
going to respond to those.
But within the domain
of faces, they're
going to respond to
pretty much all faces.
There are differences between
these different cells.
I'm going to come
back to that as well.
But it's one example
where we can actually
ask them these deep questions
about what is the neural code
and quantitative
matter by focusing
on the right stimulus and the
right place to look at it.
So we have some evidence that
monkeys, like humans, have
face regions, and
the monkey face
patches appear to be dedicated
domain specific modules.
The practical
implications of this
is that now we have
unprecedented access
to function homogeneous
populations of cells
coding for one high
level object category.
And we know this category,
we can make stimuli.
And we can modify
the stimuli sometimes
in parametric fashions.
And so we can have
very deep insights
into how these cells actually
are processing interfaces,
how they are restricting
properties from these faces.
And we can do causal
tests and actually show
whether these cells are involved
in face recognition behavior.
And we're just going to
go over this very quickly.
This is work of
Srivatsun Sadagopan,
he actually gave me
this picture of himself.
This combines the front
view and a profile view.
The logic is very simple.
So we wanted to inactivate one
particular region in a male.
I'm going to tell you
in a second why a male.
While the monkey would
be engaged in a task
like this where it is to find
a face in a visual scene.
The visual scene
that we constructed
looks a bit like this.
It's displayed on a
touch screen monitor
so the animal's
free to move around.
It has to find the
face in the scene
and the scene is
composed of a pink noise
background embedded in which
there are 24 different objects.
And the target object,
in this case the face,
is going to be
varying in visibility
across 10 different levels.
We would have other tasks where
the monkey body was included,
which you will not
be able to see here
but there is a monkey
body here or the monkey
was looking for a shoe.
Then we would infuse
muscimol which
is a pharmacological agent
that is inactivating cells
along with a contrast
agent gadolinium which
you can measure an MRI.
And then this yellow region
here is the face area now
and this white region is
the actual injection site
that we used.
And so this gives it a way for
every experiment to control,
are we inside the face
area or are we outside.
And we can use the outside
injections as controls.
What's been found is shown here.
So we have a psychometric curve.
So in normal behavior you're
getting better and better
at finding the face in the scene
as you increase its visibility.
If you inactivate, you get
a reduced face detection
behavior.
I should emphasize that we only
inactivating one face area out
of 12 in the temporal lobe.
We are only activating
one hemisphere.
And what Jim DiCarlo
was emphasizing
yesterday this retinopathy
at this level of processing.
So the animal can actually
use a scanning strategy
to go one direction and
overcome this deficit.
And so likely this effect
would be much stronger
if we had inactivated
on both hemispheres
or would have controlled
precisely for the eye movement.
But we are here for
natural behavior.
And the controls
of bodies and shoes
are, there is no effect there.
We put lots of controls and
we went to the next state
of the behavior.
We did the injections
outside as I mentioned,
it's very specific for
inactivation inside the face
area that the most basic of
face recognition abilities, face
detection is impaired.
And so there's a way
you might visualize it.
So one way to
explain this behavior
would be that the visibility
of a face like this
would actually,
with an activation,
look something like
this where it's
going to be harder to detect.
The second way we can
take advantage of this
is that we have now access
to individual cells.
We actually ask more
precise questions
about how they're
processing faces.
And actually there's
an activation study
that was motivated by earlier
work we had done on selectivity
of these cells for
features that should
be relevant for face detection.
This is what Shay
Ohayon did when he
was a grad student with Doris.
He's actually now a
post-doc with Jim.
And again, the question is
how can you detect faces even
when the lighting conditions
are very difficult.
There's beautiful work
from Pavan Sinha that's
emphasizing that
coarse, contrast
relationships in the face
of very good heuristics
to do that.
The reason is that the
3D structure of our face
stays the same even when
the lighting conditions are
changing.
And so no matter whether
light is shining from,
typically the eye
regions because they're
receded relative to
nose and forehead,
are darker than
nose and forehead.
And so he found that in
the human psychophysics
you have 12 heuristics like
this, forehead brighter
than left eye, forehead
brighter than right eye,
nose brighter than mouth,
and so on and so forth.
Twelve of these
characteristics that actually
together can allow you
to detect the face.
And in fact, your face
detector on your cell phone
is using a very similar
strategy as well.
Trying to find the coarse,
contrast relationships
in the scene.
So what Shay did was he
started with a real face,
he would parse it into
11 parts, and then
randomly assigned 11
different luminance
values to these 11 different
parts and change this rapidly.
And then the analysis
would look like this.
So no matter what the
overall pattern looks like,
he's going to look for
a particular contrast
relationship with the
forehead versus the left eye.
And he's going to ask is the
neuron responding differently
in these conditions where
the forehead is brighter
than the left eye versus
in these conditions
where the left eye is brighter
than the left forehead.
And you can do this for
all pairs of combinations
of 11 different parts.
And in these 55
different combinations,
we can mark by
arrows the prediction
from human phycophysics.
So human psychophysics told
us 12 of these constrast pairs
are going to be important.
It also told us
what the polarity
was that was going to be
important for detecting a face.
Again, forehead brighter
than eye, or eye brighter
than forehead.
OK and this is what
we actually found.
So what this shows is
a population diagram
of all the cells that Shay found
and it was half of the cells
that he recorded from that
showed some selectivity
to some of these
contrast features
and to some of these
contrast polarities.
What's plotted here
upwards is for one contrast
polarity and one
particular contrast pair,
the number of cells he
found that were selective.
And as you go through
the entire diagram,
you see that there are only a
very few examples of contrast
pairs where actually
different cells
like different polarities.
Like here for example
you have more than 60,
70 cells that all like
one polarity and not
a single one that likes
the opposite polarity.
And this is true for
all these polarities.
So it's a very
consistent pattern.
Second, we can explain all the
human psychophysics preferences
here.
Not only that, these
are important dimensions
for these cells.
But in all these
cases the cells care
for the exact same polarity
that they would have predicted
from human psychophysics.
In addition, there are other
contrast pairs that apparently
don't matter this much
in human psychophysics,
but these cells also care about.
So they seem to be using these
coarse contrast features.
And again, they're very
useful for face detection.
Now we got the behavior that
we know that the areas involved
in the face detection
with stimuli
where it's actually hard
to make out the detail.
Then Shay did a
control and I thought
this was really the
coolest thing ever.
He's a computer scientist
and so of course
he knew about databases
and how to use them.
And he would say,
OK, can we actually
fool these cells into responding
to non-face stimuli that
comply by the rules of this
coarse contrast of faces?
So here are some examples.
This is just a
pattern where there
are some dark regions where
the human face eyes might be
and so on and so forth.
This is a pattern that
only has one of these 12
contrasts correct.
But also in human faces,
you can find some--
when a person is
smiling, wearing glasses,
most of this
contrasts are actually
not in the face that
should be there.
So there are some very contrast
correct faces and there
are some faces that are not
very very contrast correct.
And now you can ask
how does the response
of the cells in the middle
face patch change as you are
increasing the number
of correct contrasts,
either on the face
or non-face stimuli.
And the answer is this.
If you increase the number
of contrasts in the face,
the cells respond more and more.
If you change the contrast
of non-face objects
the cells don't care.
So there is something
else that caused contrast
that the cells care
about, they're not easily
fooled to respond to
things that clearly
aren't faces when the coarse
contrasts are correct.
And we could actually
have predicted something
like this should happen
from an earlier study.
So the first study
we did where we
took advantage of the fact
that in a face selective area
we can record from faces
over and over again
and that they have
similar properties
was a study where we looked at
the effect of part and whole.
This is one of the central
features in psychophysical
of human faces is that you can
get information from the face
without any detail just
from the gist of the face.
An example is again
from Pavan Sinha.
If you have a blurred face
of a familiar individual,
like some of you might
recognize Woody Allen here,
of course with the glasses
it's a little bit cheating,
but you can recognize him.
And the other
examples in the study
were people who
don't wear glasses,
so you can recognize a famous
face just from the gist of it.
You don't need the details.
On the other hand, we
can process details.
We can focus on details.
And so how do these two
things relate to each other?
What we did was we
constructed a face space,
a cartoon face space, based
on very, very simple geometric
shapes.
So these faces are just made
out of ovals, and triangles,
and lines.
So very simple geometric shapes.
But if they are put together
they actually look like faces.
Now we can parameterize
this face space,
we can vary certain parameters.
So we had faces that
change in aspect ratio.
They go from Sesame
character Ernie here to Bert.
We have pupil size, like no
pupil here, very big pupils.
We have inter-eye distance here.
So these eyes are close together
almost like cyclopian fashion
or they can be very far
apart from each other,
stretching the outside of the
face and so on and so forth.
And we would now randomly
change these features,
all these different
features dimensions,
randomly choosing a new value
every time we show this face.
It looks a bit like
a cartoon character
who is trying to talk to you.
But the way we analyze
this is very simple.
So we just asked no matter
what these other features are,
for the first feature
dimension mention does
the firing of the cell change
as we're changing this feature
dimension.
Then we asked this for
the second dimension,
the third dimension, and so
on and so forth for all these
slightly different dimensions.
What we found is shown
here for one example cell.
So we had 19 different
tuning curves.
And of these 19
different tuning curves,
for four are
significantly tuned.
For this particular cell it
was face aspect ratio so didn't
like Ernie, it liked Bert.
It liked the eyes very close
together, not far apart.
It likes the eyes a little
bit narrow, not wide.
And it liked big
irises, not small ones.
What's very typical
for how the cells are
processing these features are
these ram shaped tuning curves.
So more than 2/3 of the tuning
curves have this ramp shape.
Which means that these cells
are relaying the information
that they are measuring
almost in one to one fashion.
This is not what the
cells are actually doing.
It's just a metaphor.
But it's almost like they're
taking a ruler, measuring
eye distance, and
they're relaying
this feature in almost one to
one fashion in their output.
Another implication is that
most of your coding capacity
is actually at the extremes
because many cells have
big responses there, many
cells have small responses.
So most of the
capacity is there.
That's the range where
caricatures live.
And oftentimes we are better
able to recognize individuals
based on caricatures than
the individuals themselves.
So in the middle
the face patches,
they're causally and selectively
relevant for face detection.
The cells are virtually
all face selective.
Based on these two findings
we actually suggest
and it's a little like Nancy
said as a strong signal
you're putting out that you
get backlash if there is.
So we do think that
there are modules
that are there for face
processing and face processing
only.
The gain of the tuning curve
is modulated by the presence
of the entire face.
There's this ramp shaped
tuning, which is very useful.
The cells are sensitive to
contrast relations which is
very useful for face detection.
So we can really get
mechanistic about understanding
face recognition.
It's not just that we
can say, OK, these cells
are responding more
to faces but we
can say why they're
responding more to some faces
than to others.
In fact, you can predict
from the cartoon results
how the cells are responding
to pictures of actual people
with the very fine
details physically.
And so at the level of
the middle face patches
we already have some
of the requirements
for face recognition system.
So we have mechanisms
for face detection,
we have some encoding
of facial features,
and we have encoding
of configurations.
Nancy said I should
talk about this.
I'm going to talk about this.
Sebastian Miller was a wonderful
grad student with Doris and me.
He asked the
following questions.
So whether the face pictures are
related to each other or not.
If you look at the
overall organization
these face errors are very
far apart from each other.
So the most posterior
to the most anterior
is one inch apart, it's a
third of the entire extent
of the primate brain.
They live in different
cytoarchitectonic environments.
So you could also imagine
that maybe the connectivity
is mostly local.
On the other hand, they
are interested in faces
and so you would
imagine that maybe there
are specialized
connections between them.
The way we addressed this
was with micro stimulation
inside the scanner.
So we would first
image the face areas.
We would then lower an electrode
to one of the face areas here,
we record from cells to make
sure it's face selective,
but then we would
use this electrode
to pass a current through
inside the scanner.
Passing a current
through an electrode
is going to activate cells.
That in turn is going to change
blood flow and oxygenation.
So things we can pick
up on the scanner.
And so yes, if this worked you
should get a swath of activity
around your simulation site.
But if these cells at
your stimulation site
have predictions that are strong
and focal enough to drive down
some neurons, you might
also find activation
that spatially remote
locations and they can then
see where these locations are
related to the face areas.
So here is a computer
flattened map
of the brain of one
macaque monkeys.
The green areas
indicate by outline
the extent of the face areas.
We placed our
simulation electrode
in one of the face
areas and this
is the map we got from
micro stimulation,
versus no micro stimulation.
So there's no visual
stimulus there, actually
that works during sleep
during complete darkness.
So yes, we get a
swath of activity
around the stimulation
site, and we
get multiple spatially disjunct
regions that are activated.
So they're strongly
driven by the cells
in this region and these
overlap with the face areas.
And this was either be
found very consistently
across different phase areas
if you stimulated outside
you also got this patchy
pattern of connectivity,
but now it's outside
of the face system.
And so this is the
picture that we got.
Is that yes these face
areas are actually
part of a network of face
areas that are strongly
interconnected with each other.
There's now data from
retrograde tracer studies,
we find that 90% of
the cell bodies that
are labeled after an
injection inside a face area
are inside other face areas
or in the same face areas.
So it's a surprisingly
anatomically specialized
and closed network.
So what's happening
in these areas,
and again, my movie
isn't going to work.
So in this area AL was more
anterior, also virtually
all of the cells
are face selective.
But you have a property
emerge here which
you didn't have before.
And that is mere
symmetric confusion.
And it's something
that we did not expect.
We're still puzzled by it.
We have no explanation
why it's happening.
But in this area you have
cells that like a profile view.
And if they like
one profile view,
they also like the
opposite profile view.
And this region here as
I mentioned initially
that some of the cells
did not really seem to be
face selective.
It's a small percentage.
But actually these cells are
selective for facial profile.
But if they like one profile
right, they don't like left.
If they like left,
they don't like right.
In AL, this is being confused.
And then if you go
to AM, you have cells
that respond to all faces.
It doesn't matter
where they are,
doesn't matter who
they are, doesn't
matter how big they are.
And the other cells that also
don't care where they are
and how big they are,
but they care exquisitely
about identity.
So they can be very,
very finely tuned
to identity in
particular to people
that the animals never
see in real life.
So there seems to be a
computation going on from here
to here where in Jim
DiCarlo's conceptual framework
you could imagine that there's
a manifold that's now becoming
sort of flatter and more like
a more explicit representation.
And for some reason
creating this
has to go through this
mirror symmetric confusion.
I just want to highlight.
So we meant to touch
upon the question
whether a face area should
do different coputations
from non-face areas.
Actually, my
intuition about this
was actually quite the opposite.
So I thought they would
likely do the same computation
or hopefully the
same computations
as outside the areas just
in different material.
So why in other non-face areas?
Why don't you want
to mix these cells?
We have one study that's
a little too complicated
to explain here that
gives some clues.
But some computation
work from Joel Leibo
was a grad student
with Tommy actually
gave some clues to that.
So Joel and Tommy were
thinking about invariance.
And Tommy told me
he's going to talk
about this at some later
point in the course.
The different kinds of
transformations, easy ones
and difficult ones.
The easy ones are
affine transformations.
We're just shifting something
in space or in size,
or we rotate it in plane.
And so if you learn
how to correct
for this transformation for
just three dots of light,
you can look for any image
that you can ever see.
So this is relatively easy.
But then they're non-affine
transformations that
are actually
changing the picture
and they are very
difficult. So if you
change your facial
expression for example,
or if lighting
conditions are changing,
or if you're turning
your head in depth,
this is a non-affine
transformation.
So it's not predictable
from just three dots.
And you can learn
something there
that could tell you
how this picture would
look like under this
non-affine transformation.
And one of the insights from
Joel was that if you learn this
non-affine transformation on
a particular object category--
let's say faces--
you actually have learned
nothing about another object
category like cars.
That's actually quite
surprising to me
but there could be
a reason why you
might want to have
all the cells that
have to learn representations
across one transformation put
them all in one location.
The second insight
they had, and I
think it's still
very surprising to me
that it actually
works so easily,
is to give the computation
a count for the system
that I just described to
you in qualitative terms.
So we have three
levels of processing.
So we have a front
end where cells
are useful for face
detection, they're
all very face selective.
So you could think of this
like a three level processing
hierarchy where the level one
is like a face filter that's
just going to tell you
it's their face or not.
The top level you want
an identification.
And I didn't show
the examples, again
I hope with a connection
to the monitor I
can show you the actual movies.
You have some cells that
are very, very finely
selective of facial identity.
With pattern readout
techniques you
can read out identity
extremely reliably.
If you now have like
Hebbian Learning Rule,
maybe Tommy is going to
explain this to you more,
you actually get
something pretty magic.
So you do get invariance
at level number three,
which is kind of what you wanted
and might not be surprised by.
But as a byproduct, you
are getting mirror symmetry
at level two.
And that's something you
didn't stick into the system
and it just happens,
not like magic,
but there's an
explanation for why
this happens, out of
very general assumptions
about the system.
So the point I
want to make here,
this particular
model could be wrong,
but it's something about
how knowing something
about the overall
organization of the system
might actually reveal underlying
relationships that you
might not think about.
So the fact that there are
three levels of processing
and not four or five
or six might actually
impact whether you find
mirror symmetry or not.
Or whether you find
mirrir symmetry
at one level or another level.
And you don't necessarily
get this automatically.
Just put any processing
system together.
Becuase I was mentioning
a facial motion,
I would like to give a
brief vignette of that.
And so I was emphasizing
here transformations
along this direction.
But you can see that at least
two levels of processing
there are actually
two face areas here,
one lateral to the STS, and
the other one deep inside.
And so one of the questions we
had was what's going on here?
How are they different?
And so one way you
might think about this
is again, connecting faces
to social perception.
So there are some
faces out there
that are not really faces.
And so the faces of dolls
are just one example.
So physically they are
faces but you can actually
tell that they are not
really real, they're agents.
And people like Thalia Wheatley
are wondering about questions
like why dolls are creepy.
So there is an
expectation that the face
should belong to a real agent.
And there are different
clues that can give it away.
So if the face is on top
of a body, more likely
it's an agent just like
an artificial stimulus.
If a face is moving that's
another clue it's an agent.
And this will
change fundamentally
how you interacting with it.
Your interaction with
the doll is likely
going to be very different
than with a baby.
And so again, objects
and their meaning
are making them actionable
in different ways.
And we have to understand what
the circuits are that actually
make this possible.
So one way to look
at this again is
to think about these
facial displays.
I showed the Tonkin
macaques and Clark
Fisher was an M.D. PhD student
in the lab was actually
addressing this question.
And so he made movies
like this one here.
Luckily there's no sound so
we can actually play them.
These are movies of
macaque monkeys making
facial movements of
all different kinds
of facial expressions.
And we then also have
stills that are just
changing from time to time.
And we have controls of
toys that the animals also
know that are either
moving or that
are jumping every second
from one state to the other.
And we would ask as we
had in an earlier study,
are these areas
responding to this motion
differently than to
the static images.
So here's what he found.
So he had six different face
areas he was looking at.
If you're looking at
static form selectivity
we're just reproducing the way
that the area was found just
with a different stimulus.
So all the six areas respond
more to faces than to objects.
If we now compare moving
faces to static faces,
all the arrows are
responding more
to the moving faces
than the static ones.
Some quantitative differences,
but overall the same pattern,
more responsive to moving
than static stimuli.
If you now compare on the
right inside the modulation
by moving objects
through static objects.
You can see that also all
the areas or almost all
have a slight advantage
of moving objects
over static objects.
There seems to be a general
motion sensitivity there.
But if you do the interaction
of shape and motion,
you can see that all the
areas are selectively
more enhanced by face motion
than by non-face motion.
But they all look
pretty similar.
So now you can
actually wonder if you
have a contrast like this,
like moving versus still,
there a couple of things
that are different.
So is it really about motion or
is it just about the content?
If you just show a picture
every one second you can say,
well, there's less
content there,
therefore you might have
more adaptation, therefore
less response across the board.
Is it about update frequency?
You know, a fast update
versus a slow update.
So what Clark did, he was
creating another stimulus.
If you think about
creepiness, it's actually
like a little bit creepy.
So like a scrambled version
of a motion that's shown here.
Shows us the same frames of
the movie but just randomly
associated with each other.
So if anything, now the
motion energy in this thing
is higher than in this one here.
And we can look now for
the contrast of those two
and also the contrast
through here.
And now what he
finds is actually
something where the face areas
are qualitatively different.
He finds two face
areas here which
are responding more
to the natural motion
than unscrambled motion,
and three face areas
that are responding more
to the scrambled motion
than the natural motion.
So they shift
opposite preferences.
What we think is
going in the areas
here that remember also the
benefit for facial motion
over static faces,
that they just
like a fast update of content.
Ideally in a way
that's not predictable.
If you show me something
new I'm going to respond.
And if it's something that
I can't predict even better.
So this is what
these guys are doing.
But these ones here,
they seem to be
really sensitive to facial
movement and naturalness
of facial movement.
And that was not smart.
And these areas are located
more deep inside the STS,
more dorsally, and these areas
are located more ventrally.
So there's an organization
and to discover the new face
area they didn't know before.
It's a seventh face area which
he called MD which is really
like a face motion area.
There are lots of reasons
why we're excited about this.
I mentioned the link between
face perception and agency
interpretation.
This is one possible
link, there are more.
It might be a second
phase processing system,
I'm going to go through
all the evidence.
It's only indirect, though
that this area might not
be connected to the other ones.
I told you before that the
six face areas are intricately
integrated to be one network.
This area never showed
up in stimulation,
therefore it might be separate.
And this is kind of nice
because it fits very nicely
to the human situation.
So in the human brain you
have the posterior STS face
area which is exquisitely
sensitive to facial motion.
Actually you often don't
even get it for static faces.
But it's very sensitive
to facial motion
and actually Nancy has a
beautiful study on that.
And this area by
several accounts
is not like the other face area.
So it seems to be
like a specialization.
That's another
thing, another reason
why we think these systems might
be connected to each other.
Just a cool thing
in the end, who
can recognize this actor here?
Show of hands.
OK, who can recognize him now?
So facial motion gives away a
lot of things like identity.
Jack Nicholson has very
typical facial movements.
So it's not just agency, it's
not just facial expressions,
it's also identity and lots
of things that can go away.
So we actually don't know yet
what these areas are doing.
So my summary, and I'm
sorry I'm going into lunch.
So we can do fMRI on macaque
monkeys just as in humans.
What we find we
can apply to lots
of domains within
attention studies,
found new attention areas.
Here we applied to
face processing,
we find face selected
areas for face processing.
Recording the micro stimulate--
so inactivating these regions
is supporting the notion
that these are
likely modules that
are selective for processing
faces and faces only.
These are interconnected into
a face processing network.
It looks like all these areas
have different functions
and specializations.
So fMRI experiments
are notoriously
under powered in the way of
number of different dimensions.
So if we call them
face areas it is not
to say that they're
all doing the same,
but they likely all have
different functions and likely
sub regions of these
different functions.
So again, there's no
contradiction here
to the view of a
fine organization.
Then there's a seventh
face area which
doesn't seem to be connected.
Could be separate and separate
face processing system.
We have evidence for processing
that we can understand now
in computational terms.
And this is one way
that it can link,
sometimes causally sometimes
correlationally, activity
of single cells.
Two different levels
of organization
to a very complex
social behavior.
And that's, again, I think
a very cool opportunity
to have in the domain
of social cognition
that you can actually control
stimuli very well because faces
are so powerful to get
into your social brain,
you can likely take this
approach deeper and get insight
into actual social intelligence
beyond face perception
this way.